Hi everyone, can you hear me OK?
Thank you.
They are headsets in the back just in case you
need them.
I'm going to try my best to project but I
have a little bit of a cold so I'm sorry
if my voice goes in and out so bear with
me.
So first of all, thank you for making it to
build Day 2.
And we are so happy to have a full house.
And because of that, you get 2 talks in one.
So my name is Maria Nagaga.
I am a product manager here at Microsoft working on
Foundry tools.
And I am joined by my friend over here, Joe
Flick, who works on Content Understanding.
So thank you for joining our talk.
Turn your agents into action with tools, APIs and documents.
So let's go quickly through what our session agenda is
going to happen.
We're going to do a brief announcement, but believe me,
we know you come here for the demos.
We will give you the demos, we will give you
the content to the demos, and then we're just going
to have closing remarks.
But I think we need to start this with what
does it mean to build an agent platform here at
Microsoft?
Well, it starts with building on GitHub using Foundry as
your platform where you can have your agent runtime optimize
your agents and and have all the tools that you
need.
And you can distribute these tools through M365 S Let's
zoom in a little bit more on the tool that
I sit in, like I work on Microsoft Foundry.
Microsoft Foundry allows for you to have your agent services,
models, IQ tools, a control plane, and we enable you
to govern the life cycle from cloud to edge, right?
I have been working on Foundry tools along with my
colleague over here, Linda, and we are providing this single
hub for people to have prebuilt tools, third party tools,
while providing you with the enterprise grade scalability that you
need.
So in summary, with Foundry tools, we want to have
this one in place, this one place for all your
tools regardless of tool types to exist.
But before we jump into tools, let's talk about the
single most important capability that your agent needs.
So agents and tools are rapidly growing, and this is
leading to a host of problems.
So LLMS provide you with the reasoning for your tool
for for your agent.
Tool calling is what enables your agent to perform an
action right?
And this is how your agents provide real business value.
But one of the problems that we are seeing with
our customers, they have been thousands of papers written about
this.
When you're trying to integrate tools into your agentic application,
they steering finding the right tools for the jobs.
The tool ecosystem is rapidly growing.
Who remember the time when all we had was MCP?
Who remember the time we're in now, right.
There's skills, there's plugins, there's APIs, there's connectors, there's going
to be foobar X bar.
It's going to continuously grow.
So how do we steer our tools in the right
direction?
There's scrolling.
How do we manage the tools?
How do we make sure they're securely in the place
and they're easily published?
And then there's security controlling the tools.
And it has to be incredibly important for us to
keep these secure because tools reach into your production code
and generate results.
They're reaching into your databases, they're reaching into your APIs.
And we have to make sure that not only the
agent has access to the right amount of tools and
securely, but so do the individuals who are leveraging your
agents as well.
So what does solving this problem look like?
I wish I could tell you here is a single
solution and it's done, but unfortunately that is not the
case.
This is an ecosystem made-up of various components where we
are investing in and foundry.
We have the tool catalog, which is about discovering and
publishing and installing your tools.
That sounds easy.
The next one is tool creation.
You curate a set of tools that your agent needs
in order to complete a specific task.
And then how do you actually get that curated list
and share it amongst every single agent that you might
be controlling?
There's tool discovery.
Now, sometimes when people think about tool discovery, they think
it's about you searching on a registry and finding the
right tool.
That's not tool discovery.
Tool discovery is choosing the best tool to complete the
task while using the limited amount of tokens.
How many of you want to use less tokens?
Oh, not a lot of people.
OK, you guys just like, spin all the tokens, right?
So that's when tool discovery comes and tool governance, this
is a conversation that we hear from our customers all
the time.
I love these tools, they're amazing.
But I don't want Maria to have the same access
of tools, but Linda does because Linda is better at
her job, right?
So like those are the things that we're putting together
in terms of tool governance.
So the tool catalog, let's start at the beginning.
You have thousands of tools, probably soon millions of tools
and you have multiple tool types.
And in found, we want to make sure that you
have all of those in one place.
So let's look at the tool types.
The tool landscape is growing, and it's not about just
the number of tools, it's about the types of tools.
We have open API, you're all useful, used to this.
We have MCP, we have A to a, we have
logic app connectors, we have skills, we have CLI's, we
have hooks, we have plug insurance and so much more.
So how do we make sure that all our developers
and our entire ecosystem can find all these tools in
a single place?
Last year I worked to build the tools catalog.
We shipped it in 2025.
We have one on Foundry where we have a host
of tools custom built from the ecosystem.
But in addition to that, if you need your own
private registry, you can do it as well with Azure
API Center and Azure API Management that allows to give
you that additional covenants.
So we solved the catalog problem, right?
You can get all your tools in one place.
So I want you to imagine this.
Just go with me on this journey, right?
It's a short one, I promise you, you only have
me for 20 minutes, right?
So we have the catalog and developers can find the
right tools, but finding the right tools and integrating the
tools are two different problems.
So imagine you're building a filled up agent for your
company and you have this one agent that has 6
integrations, Entra, SharePoint, ticketing, your own custom MCP or API
access to your teams, BLOB storage, Azure Search.
So this sounds simple, right?
Does it sound simple to people?
It sounds simple to you.
OK, It sounds simple, OK, You're not convinced, right?
So no, it is not simple because every single one
of those tools has its own identity, is built from
a different team, has a various set of protocols right,
and has different credential management.
Now multiply that with every single integration you need for
that one filled up agent.
But then you also have your customer support agent, your
billing agent, your networks agent, your inventory agent, and what
seems like 6 integrations ends up being hundreds of integrations,
not taking into account things like permissions, failures in debugging.
And what we find is developers are spending more time
doing integrations and less time doing what makes them money
and makes their business better, which is building agents.
So you might remember this from earlier, what's missing that
we need to solve in the agentic ecosystem, Tool creation,
tool discovery and tool governance.
Being able to curate the set of tools for your
agent, being able to minimize the amount of tokens and
over bloating into your agent in the context window and
being able to securely govern them.
And we think that toolbox is the beginning of the
promise to enable that to happen.
And this was in Satya's keynote earlier today, but yesterday.
But what is a toolbox?
A tool boxes are a usable bundle of tools managed
in Foundry that agents can consume through a single consistent
interface regardless of tool type.
That is a lot of words, so let's pay attention
to a couple of them.
Reusable.
You should be able to build a set of tool
boxes and be able to use it.
Want build it once?
Use it across any single agent.
Managed Foundry handles a life cycle for you so you
don't have to.
And finally, a consistent interface.
Your agent shouldn't have to care what the underlining tool
type is, whether it has an MCP, Open AIAPI spec
skill or a connector.
We give you 1 unified endpoint with one oath and
one experience that you can integrate into any single agent.
So what are we doing with our tool boxes?
We have 4 pillars.
Build, You create tools, you create, You create tools in
a named reusable bundle, configure and publish them.
So if you go back to our filled up agent,
you could have your filled up toolbox.
So rather than having your ENTRA configuration, your SharePoint configuration,
and all the others, you're putting it in a single
toolbox.
Regardless of toolbox to two type, you have discovery.
This is the ability that when the agent makes a
request through a prompt to the toolbox, it only retrieves
the tool that it requires to complete the task.
And then consuming, we have a single MCP compatible endpoint
that exposes every tool to any agent runtime.
So we're giving you the promises, we give you this
unified endpoint.
You can carry it across any single agent that you're
building or leveraging for your business and governed will give
you this centralized authentication and observability to monitor all your
tool calls.
And these are the features that we have built to
do this.
Toolbox is how you build them.
Tool search is the protocol that is what the tool
we've built.
So you can actually search and discover your tools at
runtime.
The unified is endpoint is an MCP compatible endpoint and
then control and visibility where we enable you to add
your own policies and guardrails And the future.
We're also going to be giving you a governed dashboard
where you can see it in more details.
So the promise of toolbox is you can consume it
across any agent, hosted agent.
You can use it in the GitHub Copilot or CLI
GitHub copilot SDK.
We want to get working in cloud code as well.
And soon you'll be able to use it also in
your Microsoft Copilot Studio application.
So the tool like my life cycle management is that
you build a toolbox and you consume A unified endpoint
and you know it's all going to be governed.
So I promise that there will be demos.
So fingers crossed, nothing breaks.
So let's go and see some demos.
All right, yeah, so it's showing up.
So I'm going to show you how you can build
a toolbox.
You can build a toolbox in code or you can
build it in the Foundry portal.
But I wanted to start by showing you what tool
configuration would look like if you did not have a
toolbox today.
So the first thing you need to do is you're
configuring every single MCP endpoint separately.
But where it gets really interesting is if I go
down to line 33 all the way to line 104,
that's all off configuration for your application.
And this is only three MCP servers.
So imagine if you required multiple MCP servers, that could
become a lot more robust very, very, very quickly.
And imagine if you're doing different protocols or like it
just gets longer and you shouldn't be spending time doing
this.
Also, this code doesn't run, it's 100% generated by AI,
but we will have demos for you to share shortly.
The next one is with Toolbox.
That's it.
I have configured authentication.
I have all my different app, all my servers in
a specific toolbox.
It will generate a URL for me and I can
then put that in any single application of my choice.
Now the last thing that I wanted to show you
in toolbox is something that we have called tool search.
And what tool search does it is a tool within
toolbox that actually searches for the specific tool within the
toolbox by leveraging and pulling all the metadata and finding
the right one.
So in that situation, you're not loading everything into the
context window, you're only loading the tool that is required
to complete the task.
So in summary, if you look at this diagram, you
can take a picture.
You're going from manually wiring every single tool to your
specific agent to just attaching it to a toolbox which
exposed to an agent through a unified endpoint.
And then tool search enables the search and makes a
decision.
So this one says I need AI, need GitHub.
It just directly picks the GitHub toolbox that is the
only one that is loaded into the context window.
Now let me take you on a tour of what
it looks like in Foundry.
You can build a toolbox in Foundry.
You can build it through code.
You can also do it in the Foundry through the
tool, the Foundry toolkit.
I always get that thing mixed up in my mind.
So sorry about that.
So when I go into Foundry today and I click
on build, you're going to present it and you go
to tools, you're going to notice that there is toolbox
tools and surprise, surprise skills.
So I'm going to start with skills and I'm going
to end on Toolbox.
So you all saw that really snazzy image that I
created, right?
I bet you all loved it.
Let's say I wanted to share it with everybody on
my team because I built a skill that enables me
to make better architectural diagrams and it works pretty well.
So I can go in here, upload a skill, browse
from my desktop, if I can find it, there it
is.
There's my art skill.
I will also make this available in the repo just
in case you want it.
Give it a name.
OK?
Must have Laura's face.
And if this uploads successfully, I'll know every single other
demo is going to be absolutely magnificent.
It uploaded, right?
So now this is available to any single agent that
is in my specific project.
Now, I told you how tools are constantly growing and
I am very excited to share that browser automation is
available today.
This is one of the new tools that we have
delivered built on Power on Playwright.
This enables you to scrape information and fill in forms.
So let me just show you a quick demo.
Now, as a person who is a horrible typer, I'm
going to copy and paste unapologetically and try to see
if this runs.
If it doesn't, the browser automation team is here in
the room.
I'll get them on stage.
I will get this running right.
So fingers crossed.
If not, I promise you I have a GIF that
actually demonstrates that this works.
OK, while we're while that's happening, I'll pretend to one
that I did earlier and there you go.
It sends it over and you will see in a
moment what has happened here is that we put in
a request of what it's going to do is automatically
fill in a Microsoft form.
OK, And that's browser automation.
OK, the next thing I wanted to show you is
how you can create and build a toolbox.
Go into Foundry, click toolbox, create, give it a name,
and you'll see the option to add tools, which shows
you every single tool that's in the catalog, as well
as an option to add skills.
So I could add the skill that I just created.
OK, there's no sales in this project.
OK, so while this loads, give me one second.
Yeah, let's we're going to switch screens because I've been
having permission issues.
Now, you know, this demo is live, but this demo
is also going to be live.
Who says CEOs are the only people who get demo
ghosts in the background?
I have one too.
OK, All right.
Is it good?
Yes, it worked perfectly.
All right, so let's go ahead.
We're going to create a toolbox.
So I added one.
So I have a toolbox here that Linda created for
me as a backup.
And you'll notice there's an option for you to turn
tool search on.
So I'm just going to turn that off for a
moment.
I'm going to set this one as default and this
is going to set the endpoint in my hosted agent
to this specific toolbox version.
So when I go over to my agent and I
am going to say.
Find me three.
Let's see if this works.
OK, all right, not working.
It is fine.
It means that they're just too many people.
So, OK, something's happening.
All right?
This, this is this is a good sign.
So what this is doing, it is going into a
work order, finding me the work order, and it should
generate me to see if the work order is complete
and if the parts are available.
OK, it worked, right?
That was a live demo.
Thank you for your patience.
Right.
OK, so I don't want to eat into too much
of Joe's time, so I'm just going to show you
one last thing in Toolbox When I go back, you
will notice that you are given a unified endpoint.
You can take this unified endpoint into any single application
of your choice.
So I want to show you one that is actually
running.
You can go there today.
AK Oh, I forgot.
Oh, the third tab.
Oh yes, the FIBI agent.
So FIBI agent is using the exact same MCP endpoint
and I want to show you this is all hosted
in an Azure Container App.
It's going to run the work order and I want
you to pay particular attention to the activity live and
the activity view.
Once it is working, it will show you which tools
are called Form Tool Search and how it was loaded.
And with that being said, I'm going to hand it
over to you Joe, because we are short on time.
Yeah.
Thanks so much, Maria.
Appreciate it.
All right, we're going to jump back to PowerPoint.
All right, so so far we've seen how Toolbox solves
problems with agents accessing tools, saves, saves tokens on tool
calls.
But now we're going to talk about agents in the
real world where all the content you want doesn't come
from.
AP is often the content you need is in the
document, it's in a video, it's in a PowerPoint deck,
and the agent needs to go access that content.
But when agents try to access that content, they often
break, they scramble costs, grow, use more tokens.
The agent tries to write custom code to go crack
that PowerPoint.
It might go miss content, it might go and try
to find a table but not be able to access
the data in the table.
These are the kind of these are the kind of
problems we built constant understanding to solve.
So content understanding takes messy multimodal content and turns it
into clean, structured agent ready output.
So you can see here the all any kind of
file can come into content understanding.
It gets parsed, classified, extracted, and turns into structured Jason
with key value pairs and markdown that represents the details
of what's in that file with high fidelity.
And this isn't just a brand new service.
This has been in GAGAD since last six months ago
and it's been in production for a year and a
half.
Foundry IQ uses it to is as its content extraction
layer to make sure it has the highest fidelity version
of the input to give you as as grounding for
your agents.
And Microsoft 365 Copilot uses it when you ask a
question about a document or PDF.
But what's most interesting about content understanding is not how
we use it, it's how our customers use it.
So we worked with customers like Walter Skewers.
They are they they build trusted professional tools for tax
automation, legal and healthcare.
And they use content understanding in their CCH access tax
product.
They use it to ingest things like tax forms, supporting
documents for taxes, other financial documents and make sure they
come in and structured format so that they can automate
your processing end to end for your tax, for your
tax prep.
Also, Data Sniper is an agentic platform for audit and
finance.
They use content understanding to power their AI extraction capability.
It's powered by content understanding, and it allows them to
take any kind of document and bring it directly into
Excel, where financial professionals want to live in structured format.
They talk about it as enabling faster reviews, more reliable
evidence, and trustworthy AI.
So with that context, we're going to dive deeper into
what content understanding is, and then we'll come back to
see the agent in that FIBBY demo in practice.
So content understanding is a pipeline, a single pipeline that
does parse, extract, and Classify.
Parse allows you to take any kind of input document
and turn it into Markdown.
Then Classify decides what kind of document that thing is
or breaks into pieces that are relevant to your scenario.
And then extract allows you to get key, value pairs
or structured content that's relevant for your particular documents out
of that content.
And this same pipeline is available for any modality.
So you can bring in any kind of file, a
video of image, document, APDF, even like old, even old
files like zip files or e-mail files can come in
and there's a custom tailored solution that gives you the
best results for that file type.
We're improving content understanding with broad coverage of qual and
quality integrations.
Here you can see we have broad coverage with new
file type supported, better quality with the GBT 5 family
of models being added as a as a engine for
running extraction and classification and then easier integration with support
for Logic Apps Agent framework laying chain.
Mark it down, a set of open source tools that
allow you to use this extraction as a part of
your agent agent runtime.
So let's drill into the improvements by each area.
Parts is where we apply Microsoft's OCR and layout technology
that we've refined over 20 years and still maintain a
state-of-the-art, continuing to approve it over as new things come
out in the, in the industry.
This gives you detailed extraction of tables of multilingual documents,
even this like crumpled page, we're able to extract some
details off of it to enable you to parse that
content.
It's the foundation of search ingestion for Foundry IQ and
we and we see here's some new things coming for
for parse in Foundry IQ.
One of the key advancements we get from using content
understanding that we'll see in the demo is that we
can extract tables well from a document and give you
structured markdown to ground your agent.
We also can extract detailed representations of figures, like charts
and diagrams from documents so that you don't lose that
content as you ingest it into your system.
Next, we'll show classification.
So once I do parse, then I might want to
classify this document, identifying the type of document it is,
or breaking a long document up into logical parts.
Many times, enterprise documents aren't just one document, they're a
set of documents in a package.
So I might have a case file, an application bundle,
or a tax submission.
It's not just one document, it's a bunch of different
things all combined in one thing.
So content understanding allows you to find the classes you
want to identify, throw away some parts of the document,
identify the key parts that you care about and extract
the the right information from each piece.
And coming in July will enable you to split your
documents not just on the page boundaries, but also on
the section boundaries as well, as that's a kiosk from
customers where you know the boundaries and documents don't fall
neatly on page boundaries often.
And so now in content understanding the classification doesn't either.
Now for extraction.
Extraction allows us to parse content into structured fields and
out structured output.
You get key value pairs, confidence scores, and grounded results.
So each of these fields extracted aren't just a completion
from an LLM, they're grounded back to a, to a
bounding box in the document, A, a word, a sentence
in the document.
So you can go directly back into the file to
find where that content came from.
And they also give you a confidence score that allows
you to auto approve when confidence is high and route
to human review when it isn't.
This is what allows customers to build real automation workloads
on top of tools like content on top of content
understanding.
And here's what's coming next with Extract in July, we're
shipping a new training process using knowledge sources so that
you can improve extraction on the documents that matter to
you.
We have, if you have a specific document like a
tax form, a financial document that matters to your industry
for your workflow, you can provide some examples.
Content understanding will train on that file and improve its
results.
Also, we'll ship new, new prebuilt analyzers that will have
significant cost reductions over in terms of tokens to be
much more efficient.
And we'll also ship a Gentic extraction.
So I'm going to drill in a little bit on
a Gentic extraction.
So it's a, it's coming in July.
Constant understanding extraction does a good job at finding answers
and summarizing data in a in a document.
But there's another Class, A broader class of use cases
that it doesn't do a great job with today.
Those cases are when an answer needs to be built,
not found, built step by step by reasoning across content
in the file.
When you have a, when you're asking a question like
for this contract and this set of amendments, which, which,
which clause applies in this, across this entire chain of
changes to this, to this, to this contract, or how
could I root cause this, this, this issue?
The just extracting, just finding a specific value in the
file isn't good enough.
You need to reason across the files to, to, to
answer those kind of hard problems.
So that's what a gentic mode will allow you to
do with content understanding.
For the hardest problems where standard content understanding doesn't work,
you can turn on the gentic and get the best
possible extractions and from from content understanding.
So this is coming in July.
We don't have a live demo here, but I'm going
to show us a quick recorded demo here.
So this is using the same grounding documents that we
showed this morning in a demo session.
Demo 331.
You can grab this QR code and go get that
repo if you're interested.
But in that demo, we show extracting from a a
very complicated fiber optic cable failure scenario.
So I have this document that describes the fiber optic
cable failure, the history of how, how it happened.
And So what I do is I ask a Genting
mode.
I, I set a set of questions to it in
the schema.
The set of questions would be things like, what's the
root cause?
How much is it going to cost to fix?
Is it on budget?
And with, by setting those questions in the prompts or
in the schema constant understanding, a Genting mode is able
to use a set of tools to reason across this
big corpus of evidence and loop over it to, to
to get a good answer Here.
It's not just look to doing a one shot, it's
able to search across it.
And if I look at what it actually does here
in the trace, it's able to go find specific evidence
in the documents.
It's able to ask, ask follow up questions about images,
to run calculations and code.
And by doing so, it's able to capture a set
of evidence to support the final answer and give me
a root 'cause that's very that's well grounded in the,
in the, in the, in the input data.
So ultimately, I'm able to get a root cause, a
cost analysis and get the right answer for this question
that would otherwise be require me to do a bunch
of custom coding to build.
So with that, I'm going to jump into the fiber
fiber optic agent that Maria showed earlier and show how
content understanding can work in that context.
First, we're going to show how content are sending works
for Foundry IQ ingestion and then we'll show it as
a context provider.
OK, so here's my demo, see if my mouse works.
There we go.
So same agent that we saw earlier with Maria, but
you'll notice on the left side over here, we have
a set of options.
There's what Foundry IQ knowledge source it's using and what
context provider the agent is using to process files at
their as their input.
So I'll start with Foundry IQ knowledge source that's minimal
that doesn't use content understanding to process documents.
I'm asking a specific question here about this F3 fiber
and it needs to ground it in this document.
You can see here this F3 fiber has a set
of measurements against it.
I'm actually asking it about this three O 131310 answer
and there's actually no evidence about what the measurement was
in that on that fiber, but the agent tells me
it's 46.
So the agent generates an ungrounded result here.
And but what we're going to see is it let's
see what happens when I turn on content understanding.
When I turn on content understanding on this file, I'll
show you what the output looks like.
So this maintenance log that we just saw will generate
content understanding, will generate this structured markdown representation that allows
me to see that missing value right there.
If I use a simple PDF parser, I can easily
miss that missing value because it just gets lumped into
this long list.
But in fact, when I turn on standard mode with
content understanding, it tells me there's no recorded separate value
here.
So it gives me the right answer now to this
difficult question, understanding the details of what's in this file.
So I also might have another case where someone emails
me a file with a work order in it and
I need to give it to the agent.
So I take this DOCX file, I give it to
my agent.
I say, can you answer some questions about this file
and add it into my work workflow system using the
toolbox that Maria said earlier.
But actually, docx files aren't supported by my agent because
typically agent harnesses have very limited file support.
This is one of the things that I can fix
by turning on content understanding as a context provider.
So context providers and agent framework allow you to preprocess
files and generate a text version that you give to
your agent.
So I can turn that on, but I'm going to
test one other thing first.
I can also just pass APDF to my agent.
In this case the agent can receive PD FS, but
again, it's using a a low quality parser by default.
So it's gives me incorrect answers.
So for example, here I asked about this work order
89, it tells me it's scheduled, but if I look
work order 89, it's completed.
So it gives me the wrong answer for what's in
this file.
So I'm going to turn on content understanding, go back
and get do the same thing again.
I'll show you what the results, what the results look
like for this file here.
Here's what content understanding generates for the output.
Again, a nice structure table.
You can also see here in this file, I have
these charts that are here and content understanding gives me
a Jason representation of the data in that chart so
that I don't lose the context of what's in that
chart.
When I go into my agent.
I can ask questions about that chart now as well.
Coming back to coming back here, it tells me that
work order a nine is complete.
It's exactly what the PDF says.
Now it knows what's there because I've given it a
good structured representation to that content.
Sometimes this isn't good enough.
Sometimes I ask a question about a file and the
file itself is complicated.
It's hard to interpret.
So I'll show an example here.
This is a a work order.
You can see here I'm asking who's the who's the
who's the field technician on this work order?
There's this Jay Martinez, he's actually the field technician.
But there's these other people mentioned like the site contact
John Smith.
I need to give the agent some guidance of how
to process this file, how to interpret it without guidance.
It says the agent, the field technician is John Smith
the wrong answer.
So I can give it guidance.
One way I can give it guidance is by giving
a creating a classify and extract analyzer and content understanding
so that it has a predefined way to process this
file.
So I'm going to switch on the right to a
context provider that uses that an analyzer from content understanding
and rerun the same question.
So I'll show you real quick what this analyzer does.
Here's a copy of this analyzer and content understanding studio,
which is where one way I can visualize and edit
these edit these analyzers.
Here you can see this analyzer classifieds the input document.
It says is it a work order and with a
description of what a work order is or is it
something else?
I could have a list of hundreds of things that
I want to classify here.
I can also classify pages page by page or section
by section as we talked about earlier.
But in this case, I'm just going to classify the
whole file.
Is this a work order or not?
And when I get a work order, it's going to
extract the technician.
And I have some guidance here about how to how
to how to pick up a technician.
It tells it this route thing is how you go
know who the technician is.
And now I have the standard business rules for my
content that I've encoded in my agent by calling this
content understanding analyzer on the input.
And by doing that, it's able to give me the
right answer.
Jay Martinez is the is the field technician.
This is exactly what I see in the file.
Jay Martinez is the field technician that got routed to
this.
And so by giving it instructions, my own business rules
on this content, now I can get the right answer
from these documents even when it's a really hard question.
So with that, I'm just going to come back and
show we, we, we showed here in this demo these
three different scenarios where content understanding is super valuable.
1 is when you're using Foundry IQ you can turn
on content understanding and that is part of your indexing
process.
You can you can extract the details of the structure
of documents, getting figure descriptions, tables out all the structure
with as little loss as possible into your index so
that you get the right answers from indexes.
And then when I upload a file in real time
to my agent, I can use content understanding as a
context provider.
Or in Langshane, I can use the Langshane primitive for
that as well.
So I can plug it into the my agent and
process files and incoming, allowing me to process any kind
of file, not just APDF, and also get the right
answers for tricky files.
And then I can also encode my business rules using
content understanding.
So I know how to process a work order or
a tax file or whatever the type of documents I
care about.
I can get that accurately represented with content understanding.
And with that, I think Marie is coming back and
we're going to thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
So I tried my best to show you how everything
worked, but I promise you, this all works.
So I wanted to show if we have three.
Oh, we have 3 minutes.
OK.
I want to try to do this.
Done.
I wanted to show you this.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
I wanted to show you like an agent that was
leveraging A unified endpoint in an agent freight land graph
application.
So this is similar to what we showed in City
and very similar to what you showed.
And I wanted you to pay particular attention to the
activity line.
You'll notice that it's going into the toolbox, loading a
spill.
It's found 10 tools, but only selected one.
It is pulling that tool, it is checking the order,
and it's generating the results back.
So rather than loading every single tool into the context
window, it's selected 1.
So I need to show you that this is real
and you can actually work on it.
Now the best thing is, is that you can try
this OOP.
You can try this all out by going to azureai.azure.com
and going to Foundry.
You can also get all our demo content in ask
dot Ms.
the build number of this this account.
And if you want to play around with the live
demo that I just showed you, you can pull this
up on your phone.
You can pull this up on your computer right now,
AKA dot Ms.
slash fibi and it will be up for the rest
of the week.
And we also have the demo code there.
So join our Discord on Foundry, try all our documentation,
the demo.
God's work with me today.
I should run my application locally later.
But thank you so much for coming.
And we'll be here asking questions like we'll be done
here.
Yes, Ralph, don't hold me to it.
Two to three months, OK.
Thank you so much.
All right.
Thank you.